nay toric Akron Beacon Journal he covers
the Cleveland Browns he was there
watching last night with Baker Mayfield
say Quan Barclay the two top rookies at
least according to the oddsmakers to win
the Rookie of the Year and they joins us
now Nate what was the reaction last
night if you're a Cleveland Browns fan
what are you taking away from that game
last night well I think it's really
encouraging you know there's plenty of
fool's gold in the preseason we all know
that but having said that I think all
Browns fans got to be happy with the
fact that they saw not just one
quarterback but two quarterbacks Tyrod
Taylor and Baker Mayfield go out and
play pretty well and actually look like
competent quarterbacks the Browns
certainly did not have that last year
and they haven't had that for most years
since 1999 so I think it was a really
nice start for those guys what's the
last time the Browns had two capable
quarterbacks on their roster well you
know I think that it would be their last
winning season 2008 when they were able
to go ten and six you know they had you
know Derrick Anderson you know well
Brady Quinn don't work out but longer
than you think Nate I'll give you a pass
[Laughter]
you know hey I know it's a bit of a
stretch but you know you know if you're
gonna go for it those would be some of
the names you mentioned the expansion
era but really this is probably the best
situation like that if I put this to a
vote for the fans who do they want to
start well I think most Browns fans
actually do want Tyrod Taylor to start
there's certainly a strong backing for
Baker Maceo but I think that most Browns
fans can get behind the idea that the
organization wants to be patient you
know I mean this is a team that
obviously he's got one in thirty-one
Hugh Jackson needs to win he knows it he
wants the veteran quarterback with a
winning NFL rec
go in there and be the placeholder for
the rookie
you know the Browns went Baker Mayfield
up either starter for the next 15 years
they don't see any sense in rushing it
and they've got a front office in John
Dorsey alonzo highsmith Elliott well who
and those guys were with the Green Bay
Packers when Aaron Rodgers sitting
behind Brett Favre and learning what
about the supporting cast with the
Cleveland Browns
well they need more they need more
receiver you know Josh Gordon
is gone and they don't know when he's
going to come back you know obviously
they had another first-round bust in
Cory Coleman's they just traded to the
bills for basically nothing a seventh
round pick in 2020 the the running backs
table is pretty promising I know the
running game didn't look at yesterday
but I think in Carlos I'd Duke Johnson
and Nick Chubb they're gonna be able to
do some things but yet the receiving
corps just isn't what it needs to be you
take Josh Gordon out of the mix I think
it's average at best and you know that's
that's you know no disrespect to Jarvis
Landry who has had a phenomenal training
camp and I think it's gonna be a really
really good player in Cleveland like he
was in Miami probably even better but
just overall there's really no proven
guys in that receiving corps other than
Jarvis well speaking of which Dez Bryant
is he coming to town that's what he says
I mean it was hilarious the
cat-and-mouse game between John Dorsey
and Dez Bryant yesterday was made for
hard knocks and you know I'm sure to be
part of this upcoming episode endorsee
met with us in the press box a small
group of beat writers who were there and
and he says that you know hey Dez is
gonna be part of this workout if he if
he just would return one of my phone
calls
so we put all those quotes out on
Twitter and all of a sudden it has
chimed in said eventually just says hey
mr. Dorsey I'm coming as a LAN to see
you Dorsey is told about it in the press
box during the second quarter and he's
laughing saying my phone's not ringing
yet oh do you need Dez Bryant do you
want Dez Bryant that's complicated cuz
they do need playmakers I mean you know
I know it does Bryant
has had his production drop in the last
few years but they need you know veteran
receiver who can really just come in and
make some plays and I think he still has
something left and you know I think that
John Dorsey would not be calling them if
you did not believe the same you know
you got Jarvis Landry on Twitter
lobbying for Dez Bryant to come join him
yeah Tyrod Taylor saying that he thinks
Dez could really help this team so you
know the Browns are definitely
interested I think the ball is in Dez's
Court we're talking to Nate Ulric he
covers the Browns for the Akron Beacon
Journal with LeBron James out of town is
there more pressure on the Browns to be
competitive I think so
just because you know Cleveland fans are
looking for that team to you know it
cite them the way that the LeBron
Cavaliers did and the Indians certainly
you know are definitely worthy of you
know enthusiasm among the fans but you
know the Browns rule even as bad as
they've been lately they're still the
most talked-about
team in town you know it really is a
football crazed region and it would
definitely mean more to Cleveland sports
fans if the Browns won than any other
team if I said to the fans you can have
LeBron stay for the rest of his career
or the Browns are gonna go to the Super
Bowl
what would they take hundred-percent
Browns go to and I'm born and raised in
Akron just like LeBron he is you know
obviously a legend worldwide and you
know locally even with him leaving twice
I think the vast majority of Cleveland
sports fans and people from Northeast
Ohio recognize how great he is on and
off the court but the Browns are still
the top dogs and and that's saying
something considering their history
since 99 did they they took down the
banner of LeBron James are those
appartments they
did somebody did somebody have an
obstructed view of downtown Cleveland
because of the LeBron James banner that
was over the no I don't think so I think
it was just an office building but
there's always discussion about who
should replace LeBron on that banner on
that building and you know the Browns
certainly have a long long way to go but
if they're even relevant again people
are gonna get excited and lobby for him
to be up there Baker Mayfield you mean
exactly okay yeah I mean you know that's
the future of the franchise right there
and I do think that the Browns really
are gonna stick to this plan to enter
this season with Tyrod Taylor as a
starter but yeah you know Baker is the
guy that they drafted is the future
they're excited about him he gave him
every reason to be excited last night
you know he's looked good in training
camp it's just that tie rod is there
they have a plan and tie rod has given
them no reason to second-guess that plan
as of yet made good stuff safe travels
back to Ohio we appreciate your time you
take care that's Nate ol Rick covers
Cleveland Browns for the Akron Beacon
Journal for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]